right welcome to scrambled and if I be
scrambled the difference because we are
in a tree wha and the fluid to
Georgetown and then took a plane landing
on a grass embankment and then took
about three hours up the beautiful Rio
River and here we are in the middle of
the jungle right on the edge of this
mighty Amazon some of their a quick sort
of Amazonian hash brown with the most
amazing delicious products ingredients
these things are almost staples in this
community for us amazing sweet potatoes
cassava and then we've got our yam x' on
here beef long beans spring onions
scallions a little touch of butter
pepper and a bit of chili these beauties
here I'm sana most sought-after peppers
anywhere in their sort of Chinese
cuisine
it's the weary weary pepper and trust me
once you've had a few you do start to
feel slightly weary because they are
powerful beyond belief and this is a
sort of almost like a really nice rustic
hashbrown but everything needs to be
caramelized for flavor
get them right now I want color on those
onions okay really important those
slightly too thin sometimes we slice
onions too thin actually burn before
they go Brown so give the onion a little
bit of body
lots of onions delicious all in
panel and then general still Oh
onions in
let's go give this hatch
paradise onion flavor that panas it's
not hot to you with the million sisters
soviet no.1 the onions fries so you're
nice and crispy
and more importantly the flavor
cast-iron pan so more than a cup of
toasted garlic again sliced nice thing
about this is sort of its rustic get
that garlic to thin is gonna burn okay
now back on there just salt
as a help get those onions even more
caramelized TSP of butter okay
it's gonna help really nice and
golden-brown season touch of salt a
little touch a red chili give us some
heat there that's such a black pepper
okay
you see now how those onions are
browning nicely but they're not burning
because I hadn't sliced into thin okay
then the cast iron pan works its magic
you can't dunk from that these peppers
they are so beautiful but be careful
because they are so hot okay take off
the little stalks
that's so powerful we do him it just
slice them down down open literally
that's it
now look at these beauties these are to
you the most amazing long beam okay
again local here and the best player
going incredible real acquittal I want a
bit of texture so mother blasting
beforehand just slice them nice okay
I'm gonna finish - with the wonderful
scallions like the beautiful French
green when I say we're in the middle
jungle here I really do mean we always a
little of jungle a hot that's free this
morning
literally just about an hour and a half
before first light had the huge roar and
it was this amazing sort of group of
monkeys that was flying through the
trees we hear that noise for the first
time it was quite scary but pretty
incredible looked out the window and
there was must've about 250-300 monkeys
just on roof crossing this jungle
throughout the night
the moon was high and his bride this is
where we need to really let do these
onions garlic pepper and beans camera
light now we start throwing potatoes in
so sweet potato first then that's just
been literally boiled skins left on nice
and then from there
saveth again really starchy but
delicious
and then the Diane's beautiful
so yes
so just on top
that's how you turn the gas up in the
jungle like to Pat it down nice and flat
so gets really nice and crispy now
unless we see that starch coming out the
flavors are incredible but keep it nice
and flat in the family feel sick and
really nice and crispy on the casada
start to break down and that starch
comes out the yams and the sweet potato
all start caramelizing flavor
that's better now
really important that down get a really
nice and crispy and the flavors and
they're incredible now with the eggs
I'd like to fry the eggs it sort of a
tablespoon of oil and then a tablespoon
of butter I'll be coming to rich with
the butter just lightly now that first
you melt it first and then crack the
eggs in there faster this was always in
and on top
yeah
my service now that he came up lightly
season those eggs
she asked I'm tough I'm also a little
touch of chili on there as well
stain the eggs very nice flavor
it's a pepper
as the eggs start flopping
possible [ __ ] their house
you know that's the color
again hit it at the bottom of the pan
and push that down I get some nicely
colored eggs are slowly started and then
finally the scallions
peace
the scallion give our sort of freshness
that wonderful hash brown especially the
top part which we don't use enough half
but I love that nice useful mellow onion
flavor
now that those eggs I start to fall and
roll around and that helps to cook the
yolk and the white nor dude just chill
that down get my butter and faced over
butter and faced over the eggs really
beautiful now that's the color ones from
there now sweetness on those onions
counter the heat of those weary peppers
back off and then finally legs slightly
trim around the side then from there
slide on the butter as well beautiful
and take that flavored butter drizzle
that way around and that is the most
amazing Amazon jungle beautiful hash
brown burst spicy Friday one of a tea
let me know in the comments what you
think of that amazing scrambled egg dish
and if you missed uncharted trust me you
can watch it on the link below or on the
NatGeo app
[Music]